th
dj
b
いやあああっこれじゃあどっあー
初めて捕手さしぶりです今日は実験的なことをやっていこうと思うんですが皆様紙飛行
機ご存知でしょうか
先ほど見たと思うんですけどなゲート飛びます
それはそうだを経ると
今見てもらった通り飛ぶわけでございます育って長打めちゃくちゃっとばじゃないん
ですよね
ためとんでも10m と部活はないかくらいの距離だと思うんですよねそこで私は考え
たこちら
サーキュレータ暴れですねそう雰囲気ですね回っと
風が起きます今はこのサーキュレーターを使ってあることしようと思います
ad
うわぁ
そういうわけで今回の柄に来年の産油レイター準備しました
紙飛行機てゴックン金の流れに沿ってこう飛ぶんですけども風がこう吹いてる方向に
こう投げると速く飛ぶならわかるして風が航空いているときに声を上げると半田飛ば
ないのは彼風が校増えてる時にコーナー切るとこう曲がるしかず
甲府一塗りコーナーいるとこうまあが瞭然に紙飛行機って風の力で飛ぶので風の動きを
自らサーキュレーターによって作り出すことによってひょっとしたら度コンティ
エージェントベルんじゃないかと思いましたよこういうことですよ
多分日[ __ ]必要なんだろうけどもういい絵をつくってサーキュレーターを申します
ちょっと fn 2分この状態で今全部サーキュレーターまーす
風がちょっとうんべきねちょっと雰囲気に公開練習はこっここ
えっとと間引きにこういう感じに帰るんだ
ひぁっ気鋭きーにょてょ
だってめんどくせて本当には直径
合鍵で無事サーキュレーター全部もありましたぜ的にはいいから絶対に強い
これいけるんじゃないかね1持って1件が未登記をこの渦の中に入れてみますよねぇー
もっとスピードちょっと風が強い
全部風ツアーでやってみましょう
なんでちょっと場を広げてみますこれで方良い天気誰でしょ
作戦変更しますもっと大きな絵にした風をちょっと強くしましょう
ん
結構広めにとりましたこれならためいい感じに回ってると思う
もうこれ税収とかでもよくね
ホロッコ
募集では飛ばしてみましょうこれはビッグウェーブん
3ちょっと
一番はやっぱりも問う違う
あああああ
ああああああ
こういうことじゃないんだよなん
ai
me
teame
uh